All right,
I'm going to talk about imperialism today.
And so this compliments the chapter in that,
um,
in the book.
Um,
so the main topic is the new imperialism
and
the lecturer is,
and very much about the culture of imperialism,
uh,
because part of the age of mass politics,
in Europe and the,
and the 1880s,
nineties for World War One,
um,
involved a massive support for the new imperialism.
So what was new about the new imperialism?
Uh,
and,
and when,
when,
what period did we talk about,
uh,
as having a,
having had the new imperialism,
it,
it's really from the mid eighties,
just say the 1880s to a 1914.
And so at that point,
as you can see from the maps in the book,
and you can see from the,
uh,
the discussion that,
that the European powers a really conquer the world,
there's no way a other way to put it.
And there's a frenetic or wild chase even to the South Pole,
you know,
as part of that.
Um,
and after the African continent of which there were huge blanks in,
in,
in the maps of,
of Africa,
uh,
by 1914 number,
virtually entire continent was not only charted,
uh,
but had been conquered.
Um,
and so Europeans,
uh,
really control a of the globe,
the Americans in a,
in a,
in a smaller way,
but,
but are part of,
of,
uh,
of the new imperialism.
Um,
so let me just start out by posing the question and I sent all this stuff around
too.
So it's like I don't have to scribble on the board and you don't have to try to
figure out what it is.
It's written on the board cause it's hard to see from here,
um,
that if you were going to argue or to point out or to claim that there was a,
a,
a central reason for the new imperialism.
Why,
uh,
even Bismarck who described the colonies as an albatross around the neck of
Germany?
Well,
he gets into the kind of feeding frenzy himself.
Uh,
uh,
it's been putting rather clever layer cleverly by guy called bomb golf so long
time ago,
uh,
that it comes down to God gold and glory that,
um,
there were those who interpreted the mad quest for colonies is as being,
uh,
the missionary impulse.
A sort of subset of this would be the French idea that there was a civilizing
mission going on and trying to,
uh,
trying to give,
give a indigenous peoples access to French culture.
But basically it's,
it,
it argues that that Dutch Calvinist ministers and Lutheran ministers and
Catholic priests,
uh,
and,
other denominations,
uh,
encouraged,
states and their own church people to,
uh,
to bring to their religion indigenous peoples all over the place.
Well,
we can dispense with that one.
That was part of it.
Of course.
I mean,
you can't distinguish any of these three and say that each at any of them are
new,
but,
uh,
that,
that is a rather small part of the quest for,
uh,
for yet more colonies in the new imperialism.
And indeed for all of the,
uh,
the well meant,
however it will condescending in many cases,
a quest for conversion,
religious conversion.
Uh,
most of the Lutheran ministers and Dutch Calvinist ministers and South East Asia
and Catholic priests,
uh,
all over the place such as Vietnam,
or my friend Charles Keith has just finished a dissertation on Catholic Vietnam
and the 1920s,
most of those priests,
uh,
in,
in areas such as Africa were there to 10 tour to the religious needs of,
you know,
of the European communities is particularly true of,
of,
for example,
Lutheran ministers in German,
a southwest Africa.
Uh,
and,
and in other places,
uh,
the,
the drive to convert a people's to,
to organize European religions was probably a greatest.
And it,
you know,
the Vietnam case is a very good one.
And the role of the of the Catholic church is extremely interesting in Vietnam
and the origins of,
of Vietnamese nationalism.
Uh,
but that,
that is another story.
Now,
the second one was,
was Gold Gi,
put a d for the g o and gold.
Was it spelled g.
O.
L.
D usually.
Um,
and,
uh,
I,
I said in,
in what you're reading that if you,
if you,
if you get Karl Marx,
the fever sat together with Hobson,
you know,
a very major economic thinker who might describe it in there.
Uh,
if they were having dinner there,
there'd be a lot of WWE was uncomfortable about the dinner,
but they would really agree.
They would say that,
that the new imperialism of which obviously Hobson was a great critic,
you know,
emerged out of the quest for,
uh,
for riches,
for resources and part of,
of Marxism.
And,
and part of Leninism an important part was that imperialism was sort of the
final stage of the development of capitalism.
And that,
that states need new markets.
They need new resources,
uh,
and therefore a,
they set off a set out to,
uh,
at a time of economic,
a crisis.
I mean,
nothing like now,
but there is a depression that lasts from 1874 to the mid eighties,
nineties.
Uh,
they set out to define new Richards and that the people are going up the Niger
River,
for example.
Uh,
uh,
where I've been in,
in Molly and Molly.
Uh,
they,
uh,
you know,
they expected to find gold around the next bend or more peanut oil or,
or,
uh,
or diamonds because of the,
you know,
the diamond rush and South Africa,
which was the equivalent of the gold rush in the u s and about 1848.
And California.
Um,
and Hobson was,
no marks is at all,
but he said,
and he was a critic of the,
you know,
the brutality of the new imperialism,
which I'll talk about in a minute,
but,
uh,
he said,
if you want to find out where this all began,
you look,
you look at a high finance in the city,
the city being,
uh,
the city in London,
Westminster,
uh,
where the high rollers and the bankers and the big capitalists are,
and there is your,
there is,
there,
there is the origins of the,
of the new imperialism.
Um,
now there were critics of the new imperialism and most of them,
but not all,
were in Britain.
And,
and,
and many of them opposed the new imperialism because of the brutality,
uh,
of,
exerted on indigenous peoples,
uh,
by,
by the imperial powers.
Um,
and there was a real wave of opposition,
for example,
to a imperialism that swept through,
uh,
Britain and London in 1900 in what they called the,
um,
the,
the khaki election khaki,
because it was the color of,
of the uniforms,
uh,
of many of the British,
soldiers,
uh,
in,
in hot,
in hot climates.
Um,
and so,
uh,
some of the opposition,
in the,
the Liberal Party,
um,
some of the,
uh,
we're,
opposed,
uh,
ran on a campaign of anti imperialism and they were just wiped away.
They were just absolute swept away in the elections of 1900 and ordinary people
in a,
in Britain,
a thrilling to the accounts of colonial,
uh,
exploits,
voted overwhelmingly from the conservatives who just blow the liberals out of
the water and,
and,
and the Labor Labor or the party exists in 1900 bridges.
Not yet,
uh,
you know,
a major,
uh,
a major force.
And so,
uh,
imperialism,
um,
uh,
carries the,
carries the day and,
and the big parades in London of returning soldiers from the Boer War in South
Africa and from other wars,
from all the wars,
uh,
they agreed to this conquering heroes.
Nowhere more a frenetically enthusiastically exuberantly then the city,
uh,
cause there is a link between finance and a big finance,
big capitol and imperialism plump,
uh,
period.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
besides that we have a category we call social imperialism.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the imperialist power said he and saw imperialism as part of the overall
strategy of,
of,
um,
you know,
of conquest is,
look,
if you've got economic problems at home and you've got a lot of unemployed
workers also in France,
if you've got a lot of unemployed workers who happen to be socialists or in
Italy,
that you can kind of export your problems because you can point people in the
direction and say,
Hey,
you going when times are tough here,
but if you go to Algeria,
you know,
we'll rip off some Arab land for you and you'll be just fine.
Or you can go,
um,
you can go,
uh,
make it rich in,
in Vietnam or you can go to Kenya or to Ghana.
I would have become Kenya,
Ghana.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so you can export your social problems.
And this is sort of a new imperialism.
Uh,
man,
uh,
you know,
classic case would,
would be,
uh,
you know,
the insurrection of 1851,
this is backing up before the new imperialism,
but what do they do with the people who are arrested after the revolution of 18?
Uh,
I mean,
uh,
the instruction of 1851,
a lot of them are sent to Algeria.
You export your quote unquote social and political problems.
And the irony there,
amazing,
delicious irony is they're a great,
great,
great grandchildren.
Ended up being a right wing supporters of the national front and before that of,
of at various right wing groups that,
that believe in,
in French,
Algeria.
Uh,
and who tried to keep their friends from Legion leaving Algeria in,
uh,
in 19,
the early 1960s after the Algerian War of independence.
So I'd be social imperialism is part of it as seen by,
you know,
uh,
by,
um,
sort of the economic cannon,
uh,
that is the way of thinking about the economy and the political economy of,
of these countries.
Uh,
as a way of keeping things calm and home is that,
you know,
give people opportunities.
You send them to these foreign places.
Uh,
and Geez,
I mean,
in the case of France,
I remember reading,
you know,
reading these,
this gripping,
I'm just pathetic stories of these people just can't make it in,
in the area in which we live in the south of France.
And,
you know,
they pack up all their stuff and,
and you know,
they walk,
you know,
they walk or they get a little push cars try to get to avenue.
I'll try to hit the mouse day,
try to get a boat to,
uh,
to get to Morocco,
Tunisia or Algeria to try to make a living there.
And this too is part of social imperialism.
And as part of,
you know,
the idea that somehow that social imperialism is economically determined,
that is the final stage of capitalism.
Well,
is that the biggest reason?
No,
but it's damn important.
The biggest reason is it has to do with,
uh,
the entangling alliances and great power rivalries,
that,
uh,
and it's mostly wrapper.
It's represented best by far,
showed up,
uh,
at the end of the,
1890s where British force stumbles into a French force in the middle of Sudan
and they say nasty things to each other.
Finally toast each with drinks they had brought along,
uh,
and the other countries almost go to war,
because the flag would be tarnished by,
by losing out to your craven reptiles that you just stumbled into in,
in,
uh,
in the Sudan.
Uh,
and imperialism.
The new imperialism is one of the fundamental causes of World War One period.
And that is the biggest reason now,
don't get rid of the,
the of the gold interpretation completely.
Pink is obviously as Britain and Germany become huge economic rivals,
big economic rivals as,
as the,
uh,
as the Germans are not only nipping at the heels of,
of,
of the city and a British industrial production in British naval production,
but passing them and things like chemistry and in,
in,
uh,
in production of steel and the production of big battleships.
Uh,
all this stuff runs together.
Your,
your victory is your craven reptile opponents loss.
And that's the way they viewed it.
And most people are.
I'll do,
I'll talk about this on Wednesday.
It's fun to talk about,
uh,
sad,
but also fun.
Uh,
you know,
most people in the 1890 [inaudible] thought that the next war would involve
France and Britain.
There'll be fighting again.
Uh,
and,
and they're rivals here and there,
or they thought that maybe the British and the Russians would fight because
they're rivals and what was called the great game,
you know,
for India and Afghanistan,
and it was north of India and all of that.
I mean,
the,
uh,
so,
but basically glory and the imperial,
I mean,
the rivalries great par rivalries is,
is the biggest reason,
uh,
that,
Germany gets into a,
uh,
into the imperial game.
For example,
you know,
Bismarck,
it's a famous Bismarck story.
Uh,
I'm really awful man,
but,
uh,
there,
there's a,
when there's a imperial lobby comes racing along and says,
look,
you know,
uh,
chancellor,
hair chancellor,
we really need to have the troops go and protect our merchants.
People like the sort of freelance guy.
Uh,
uh,
Carl Peters.
Uh,
and he said at one point,
he slams down a map of,
of Europe on the table,
and he says,
that's my map of Africa.
Here we are,
and we're surrounded by Russia and France.
But by,
toward the end of his career was completely different.
And he's backing up,
uh,
German expeditionary,
I mean,
a German merchants with expeditionary forces and once Plat plant the flag and
then you'd better defend it.
But the,
and the big issue there is rivalry with,
uh,
um,
you know,
with France,
uh,
and with Russia as Bismark says,
he says,
Jeez,
you know,
if we can get the,
the French interested in all these colonies in Africa,
then they won't be dreaming of reconquering,
Alsace and,
and,
uh,
and much of the hen,
and then at the,
and he says,
well,
you know,
we better be out there too.
And they're all out there.
And as some wag ones puts it.
Italy gets into the game too with,
with in Libya and Ethiopia with a huge appetite in bad teeth as someone wants,
as if someone was put in,
of course they get defeated in the battle and in 1896 and then they will pay
them back with it,
a poison gas and cascades of bombs in the 1930s and just destroy everybody and
kill them all if they can to pay them back for their defeat in 1896 now I am
eventually going to talk about,
about the politics,
about the culture of imperialism and give you the example which I find telling
of Robert Baden Powell and the origins of the boy scouts.
You didn't associate the boy scouts with imperialism,
but you will in a minute.
But first,
uh,
you know,
let me just say that,
that this is not,
you know,
some sort of seventies radical guy saying,
oh,
you know,
it's really,
they're,
there he goes again,
it's really nasty to be slaughtering a hundreds of thousands of people,
but it is nasty and that's what they did.
And that cannot be forgotten.
And it doesn't just start with the,
the famous case of,
of the Germans in southwest Africa.
More about that in a minute.
Uh,
visual,
uh,
the name is quite forgettable,
but who's a general from,
from an emotional,
you know,
the French,
uh,
conquer LG or is any way in 1830 as a political diversion.
And gradually they expand their control over,
uh,
Algeria.
Um,
and Algeria becomes a,
it becomes a colony and it becomes an integral point of view,
integral point of view from the point of view,
the French of,
of,
uh,
in a different way than Tunisia is Vietnam or Morocco and other places,
of,
of France,
even though it's not part of Metropolitan France was Yo,
uh,
and his successors kill about 850,000 people,
during the campaign.
A very unequal,
uh,
battles in Butoh comes up with the idea of simply putting,
men,
women and children into these huge cat,
uh,
caves and caverns and then simply throwing bombs in.
And so they all die.
And he did that over and over again.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
it's easy to say,
well,
the demons of the 20th century,
they come into the 20th century,
don't they?
But as I suggested before,
in terms of the commune,
I mean this stuff is out there.
I in the 19th century as well.
And so racist ideologies out there in the 19th century,
there's no doubt about it in the French experience,
in,
it wasn't that where in every place,
uh,
but the French experience was pretty terrible.
And the case of,
um,
you know,
the,
uh,
no very well documented case of,
of,
of what happened and what now is Congo and was in Zaire.
Uh,
we're sort of the private,
uh,
private colony of the king of Belgium.
Uh,
the atrocities there are well known and one could go on all day talking about
these atrocities.
Uh,
the most well known,
uh,
certainly,
and most well documented and in a way because of what comes later in the 20th
century is that of,
uh,
of um,
the conquest and indeed genocide and the here on borrowing a term appropriate
term.
I think in this case.
And that's not a term you throw around
very loosely.
Uh,
of my friend and a colleague,
Ben Kiernan,
who some of you know,
big book on,
on genocide,
which you'll press published,
uh,
recently.
Um,
they begin conquering southeast or southwest Africa in 1885.
Uh,
so Bismarck still has a few a years to go.
Um,
and um,
in their way as they would see it among other people where the heroine hair
hair,
a Bantu Group of about 75,000 cattle herders who were in the center of what
would become the German,
uh,
colonial territory.
Now again,
I mean this is European powers or are putting things like borders their
boundaries and that has nothing to do with the,
with the way that,
that,
that particularly nomadic peoples,
they don't have any sense of,
of borders.
I mean,
Molly,
where I,
I've been,
uh,
cause my daughter was studying the,
a Megan in Mali,
in northern Mali,
north of,
of of Timbuktu.
I mean the,
the,
the two of meg who are a,
people had no sense of borders.
There were two of them hag across other borders too and borders or something.
We're artificially constructed by these powers to stay.
We're here,
our empire goes there and yours doesn't start till there.
And so,
um,
as these people,
you know,
rise up to defend their own territory,
they are systematically,
um,
uh,
a massacred,
um,
and um,
they basically,
um,
first decide to crush the uprising,
uh,
at,
um,
at all costs.
Uh,
and there is a in 1904 and extermination order.
Um,
and that's literally that the German trend translation from the German,
uh,
the proclamation of the local militia commander is that the horror people must
leave this land.
If he,
they don't,
I will force them to do so by using the great gun that is artillery within the
German border that is defined as now German.
Every male Herrero armed or unarmed with or without cattle will be shot to
death.
I shall no longer receive women or children,
uh,
that is,
spare them,
but we'll drive them back to their people or have them shot.
These are my words to the Herrero,
uh,
people now.
Um,
I couldn't make this up and it's easy to say my how terrible this is,
but it is terrible.
And it was part,
it was part of the,
of,
uh,
of the enterprise and has remained the part of the imperialist enterprise.
It wasn't the goal of every imperialists to,
uh,
to exterminate the people who were there.
Uh,
but if they got an a way,
uh,
in a very unequal fighting,
in,
in India,
there were various cases of soldiers complaining it was too easy as shooting
down the,
uh,
the rebels because it was just like hunting.
There was a very British upperclass analogy.
It was just like,
I just like hunting.
Um,
and,
um,
so basically what they do,
if they don't shoot them,
they chased them out into the desert and then they cement over,
uh,
the,
the wells in the oasis.
So they die.
And basically they exterminate about two thirds of the people.
There's a very excellent book on this written by a former graduate student here
many moons ago called Etsy Hall,
Isabelle Hall,
that was published four or five years ago.
So,
um,
you know,
th the origins of,
of this and,
and,
and again,
I mean there are people not writing and saying,
well,
it wasn't that bad.
You know,
they brought trains to India and did the,
ended the huge disparities and prices.
I mean,
certainly lots of good things.
I did come,
but,
you know,
looming in the background were,
were,
uh,
were these massacres and,
and know the addition that I'm working on now that I'm just finishing of,
of,
uh,
the book that you're kindly reading.
Uh,
there's a whole recent spate of interesting literature.
I on the end of the British Empire in Kenya,
uh,
in the 1950s,
the 1950s.
History of the hanged is one.
There's another one by a woman called Carolyn Elkins at Harvard.
And the title escapes me at the moment,
but are just fantastic.
But just gripping,
just chilling,
you know,
accounts of,
of,
uh,
essentially the,
you know,
the mass murder,
uh,
incarceration and murder and shooting under the guise of trying to escape in
quotes and all of this,
of,
uh,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of people.
And this was hidden from the British public,
just systematically by the government.
So it's a long,
it's a long story and it's one that we have to wrestle with.
Now,
having said that,
uh,
I want now to talk about the culture of imperialism.
So this is sort of shifting gears rather rapidly and talk about,
uh,
Robert Baton Powell.
Baden Powell is the best way of,
of of pronouncing it,
uh,
and the origins of the boy scouts.
And again,
because I was once asked to leave the boy scouts in Portland,
Oregon,
cause that was of no use and it never accumulated a single badge.
This is not the origins of this,
of this lecture.
And there's lots of stuff written on being Paul.
He's an easy person to mock.
He's an easy person,
I suppose,
to have some sort of respect for two in a way,
depending on your point of view.
And I'm not dissing the boy scouts once I had people running up,
but I said woman or even became up was a girl scout and she says,
oh,
this is so cruel.
What you're saying about scouting.
It's not like that.
I know it's not like that now.
Uh,
but having had some relative who had a very strange idea of giving me of all
people boy's life as a birthday present and I remember,
you know,
reading that and all this kind of,
this kind of over the top of Americana and publications,
I suppose I'm wracking a little bit,
uh,
against that too,
but,
but the,
there is a point to all this and,
and so the rest of this is about Baden Powell,
I and,
and the boy scouts.
Um,
Robert a Baden Powell was a,
was a soldier I,
and he believed,
he came up with the idea of scouting as a way of preparing a
British youth for a imperialism and for,
uh,
the next war.
Um,
the origins of the,
of the scouts in terms of its timing,
that is the first decade of the 20th century has to be seen in terms of these
international conflicts is international great power rivalries with which,
you know,
we began,
it,
it comes at the time of the Brock and affair,
the first Moroccan affair and the second Moroccan affair,
1905,
1911 when it seems like the British or the French and the Germans will,
will,
will go to war against each other and they will bring in the other great powers.
Uh,
more about that.
Robert Baden Paul was a professional soldier and when he went back to,
to England,
he,
uh,
he thought that the,
that British youth were a cigarette smoking,
heavy drinking,
you know,
flabby,
uh,
weaklings whether they were upper classes and even worse.
Uh,
he had his few lower classes because they were underfed and therefore a smaller,
he,
he hated the Oxbridge common rooms.
He said with his town,
life buses,
hot and cold water laid on,
everything is done for you.
Uh,
the British working classes like that,
like the upper classes tended to drink a lot.
Um,
he was sure that there'd be a war fought in the lifetime of these same people.
And he came to the idea of scouting.
Now America has a role in,
in,
in all of this.
I mean,
we,
we are,
uh,
this country,
has always believed in the frontier.
Those of you who had the Glen this course in American history and other people
know about the Turner thesis,
about,
you know,
always you can expand to the west,
you can diffuse your social tensions and the east by giving people access to
land,
you know,
further on and get rid of the Indians and the way,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Now,
uh,
it,
you know,
we have friends that still [inaudible] friends in France who still read the last
of the Mohicans,
you know,
and there's this fascination with the American frontier,
and this is extremely important.
And the end of,
uh,
of the,
of,
uh,
of the 19th century,
in,
in Europe.
Um,
and so Baden Powell,
um,
he borrows the uniform of the boy scouts from the frontier,
uh,
from the frontier uniform,
as,
as he imagined it,
uh,
on,
um,
uh,
you know,
in America,
the cowboy hat,
the flannel shirt there neckerchief the sh achieve the short,
uh,
her reset,
the short pants.
He said,
the shape of a face gives a good guide to a man's character.
The sort of from face.
He loved that square jaw compared to working class loafers and,
and shirkers has as he called them.
And it's this cult of,
of masculinity.
Now this comes at a time one,
my stay,
when you've got very aggressive suffrage ism us by the suffragettes who want
the rights of women to vote in,
uh,
in Britain,
one of whom,
uh,
throws herself in front of a horse in a horse race and sacrifices her life to
make a point.
It comes at a time as the author at the famous Oscar Wilde,
uh,
try,
trials.
And Oscar Wilde,
of course,
was gay.
Uh,
and,
and there was a sense that,
you know,
the reality of English manhood.
I was being tested,
being tested by,
by women,
by a,
and the bad Baden Powell did not like women.
He referred to women as,
as silly women,
uh,
silly girls,
silly women,
uh,
and by,
you know,
and,
and by gays whom he saw as,
as,
as a feminist and,
and therefore not really British and wouldn't be there.
What good could,
could they do,
uh,
in,
the next war.
Also,
it's a time where in Germany particularly,
but only in Germany,
not only in Germany,
we're dueling,
there's sort of that test of,
of masculinity where you,
if you're lucky,
you'll end up with a dueling scar and not actually get killed.
And most of them don't get killed,
but they're dueling all over the place there.
They're dueling in the woods outside of Paris.
They're dueling almost everywhere.
Germany,
they're dueling still in,
in,
in Britain.
And that's what a reaffirmation according to Bob Nye and lots of other people
and all sorts of people have written on this and who to flavored.
My colleague who's now gone.
And unfortunately,
um,
you know,
this is,
uh,
this is part of the reaffirmation of reality.
And the tendency is to say,
looking back,
I said,
well,
they're taking it out on animals,
blowing the hell out of them.
Uh,
and uh,
indigenous people,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So scouting for boys takes off.
It spreads from,
from Britain to Australia to Canada,
to New Zealand,
to India,
to Chile,
to Argentina,
to Brazil in 1910.
It starts in,
uh,
the United States.
And in 1910,
Baden Paul reside resigns from the command of a division of the territorial army
to spend the rice to the rest of his life involved in scouting.
And again,
what I'm saying is that this is involves a sort of grasping on this idea of the
American frontier.
You're going to create your new frontier.
You're a new frontier is going to be an Africa.
Your new frontier is going to be in Afghanistan.
Uh,
you,
you create your frontiers and then you hold the frontiers and you train these,
these boys,
uh,
these young men to hold the colonial,
frontier.
And he founds,
he finds sponsorship and the daily Cat Telegraph,
which was a big conservative newspaper.
All the big newspapers are conservative.
Um,
and the 60,000 scouts,
I think I sent this around,
but 1909,
there's 60,000 scouts and Britain 1910 or 107,000,
1913,
150,
2000.
And in 1917,
194,000.
Why was there such a short gap that much of a leap between 1913 and 1917 because
their dad,
they get killed.
They killed in the war.
I mean they're going off to fight there scouting
as a finished a,
uh,
a rather early.
Uh,
you've got these big rallies,
enormous in London,
scouts coming from all over the empire.
Girl scouts are created in um,
in 1914,
but,
uh,
Baden piled in the eye care much about that.
Now there had been groups of frontier inspired,
you know,
youth organizations that existed in Scotland particularly,
and they're called things like the sons of Daniel Boone that woodcraft Indians.
The boys were glade in brigade in Glasgow in 1883.
Some were church sponsored.
Again,
this is the sore moralization of the working classes.
Uh,
you get them into groups.
They won't smoke cigarettes,
which is a good thing not to do a,
they won't drink.
Uh,
they want to hang out with the wrong people.
they will go to work and become cogs in Britain's,
uh,
industrial,
empire.
And they too can look at maps of,
of,
of Africa being increasingly painted red,
which was the color of the,
of,
of the,
uh,
of the empire.
Um,
and so nature,
uh,
remains,
a part of this now,
um,
again,
to repeat the cult of the American frontiersmen,
let me say a little bit more about that.
Uh,
is,
is part of this,
the idea of the fronts.
Tears man,
the buck skin man,
uh,
Rudyard Kipling,
you know,
I mean,
Roger Kipling is not my kind of poet,
but anyway,
um,
he,
he expresses often this,
this idea something hidden.
Go and find it.
What's happening.
Uh,
uh,
what I put must have pushed something.
I pushed something.
It doesn't matter,
not easily alarmed.
Uh,
go and find it.
Go and look behind the ranges,
something behind the ranges,
uh,
lost and waiting for you go.
Baden Powell described the frontiersman who's manhood is strong and rich of a
pure life.
Now his own PR,
uh,
again,
he,
his own predilections is that for him,
a pure life would not involve a silly women quote unquote as he put it.
But,
but the other idea is,
is,
uh,
and this is not,
you know,
there's not at all,
I'm not saying anything about you know,
his sexuality,
but I mean,
the reality of the situation is that he preferred the company of,
of,
of young men,
uh,
to,
to any anywhere else.
And this is involved in,
in,
in the way he lived his life.
Um,
and,
um,
but the idea is that the Freeman must earn independence with his gun.
Uh,
and this is again,
part of this old American,
a Western idea,
but you apply it to,
uh,
um,
indigenous people.
Now you have aggressive models coming from the American West,
William Wild,
Bill Cody from our white,
my wife's state of Nebraska had killed thousands of buffalo.
He had Dewald,
you know,
dual,
I mean,
these aren't,
you know,
the duals that they do in the,
with with the Bush,
the German dueling fraternities.
You got the equivalent in dodge city in all of this where you're dueling and
they have the classic kind of Clint Eastwood,
uh,
a western.
He'd killed thousands of Buffalo Dewald and he's a killer.
And Scott and,
and scalper of Indians.
He was his own publicist and he had enormous influence in Britain.
After the battle of the,
at the battle of little big horn in 1876,
he kills Indian chief yellow hand.
In 1887,
he crosses the Atlantic,
he goes to London,
Paris,
and Berlin Queen Victoria came out of her period,
extended period of decades of mourning for her dear husband,
Albert,
uh,
to attend a wild bill Cody show.
She wants to go.
And she's there with all of the others.
Uh,
she hadn't been to an event like that in 26 years.
Um,
and so the irony is that wild bill,
Cody,
when he runs these,
you know,
these fake combats between the,
between the Indians and the cowboys,
you know,
in,
in stadiums or the equivalent of stadiums in Britain when the ironies of this
about art and,
and railed emerging if at some of the people he brought across the Atlantic,
we're Indians who had actually fought in the battle against him in the DAKOTAS
and he hires them as extras and he takes them to Paris,
to London and to Berlin.
And they are a big,
huge success.
Uh,
it's the wild west program,
um,
in north the same time in Canada.
Those are your Canadian know about the,
you know,
the mounted police and all that business.
And the mounted police become a powerful though,
somewhat tamer,
more acceptable,
more vanilla equivalent of that,
of keeping order,
you know,
in Saskatoon and all of these places like that actually been the Saskatoon as
says,
it's a pretty nice place.
Um,
and so the idea of these mountain men and amount of the mountain men get your
uniforms,
you know,
the mountain men's are no augers or you know,
taking pot shots at people in Kentucky on the frontier or scalping Indians in
the Dakotas.
They're wearing,
you know,
so freelance scalpers,
they're wearing the uniform of these countries and they're big time
imperialists.
And so that's really the point.
Um,
here's a verse I can't remember where I got that.
Our mission is to plant the right of British freedom here,
restrain the law,
lawless savages and protect the pioneer.
It rhymes and tis are proud and daring trust to hold these vast domains.
But with 300 mountain man,
you've got to kind of make that rhyme a little bit mountain man,
like,
uh,
pronounce it is if you were a mountain man.
But anyway,
that's a little harder to do if you have an Oxbridge accent.
Uh,
which I clearly don't.
Um,
you know,
also,
this is part of it and the whole,
I mean,
I don't have time to do it and I've spent a fair amount of time in Australia,
but it's also part of the whole,
the idea of being Australian.
Two of you know of.
But anyway,
but that's a,
that's another thing.
It a Kipling's loss legion is really just awful.
But,
but here we go.
Ah,
there's a legion that was never listed that carries no colors or crest,
but split in a thousand detachments is breaking the road to the rest.
I'm supposed to be more respectful when I do this.
But anyway,
our fathers,
they left us their blessing.
They taught us in groomed us and crammed.
But we've shaken the clubs and the masses to go and find out and be damned dear
boys to go and shot and be damned dear boys.
A realty,
adventurous loyalty,
loyalty to boys,
loyalty to young men and,
and brotherhood.
Uh,
and so,
um,
it starts,
uh,
like that.
Can I barely go on out from the woods of the great northwest under the Austral
die from the south and the north.
They'll,
they'll come forth at the sound of the mother's cry and each at his post where
the danger is most will stand as a century then Britishers all to stand or to
fall.
The empires,
frontiers men.
Now Baden Paul is his own best publicist,
uh,
even better than wild bill Cody and Ben.
He helps plant newspaper articles about him.
Uh,
here's one from 1900.
It's been suggested that Major General Baden is unrivaled skill as a calvary
scout forms of quite remarkable inheritance of heredity.
That he is descended from Pocahontas,
the American Indian princess.
Uh,
which he was clearly not,
but how does it become so popular and how do these poems,
he's got off of poems that I've just read.
How,
how do they become popular?
They become popular because they become the stuff of,
of boys literature,
of the culture of imperialism.
They were the British equivalent of boys life.
I don't even remember.
I'm not knocking boys life.
I don't know if that existed.
I strongly preferred sports illustrated and the sporting news,
uh,
to that.
Uh,
so they become the stuff that people are reading it.
They're looking at these maps of African gradually becoming painted British.
Now how did he become well known?
Well,
because he's an imperialist and he's fighting in 1896,
uh,
he fought in the metabolite war,
which I sent around,
not the war,
but the name a skirmish against about a thousand,
uh,
indigenous of fighters.
Um,
and it's at that point where he starts,
uh,
starts coming up with his own freelance uniform that would become that of the
boy scouts and in the middle in military units,
people that were scouts,
again,
the idea of tracking of your tracking,
you're seeing where the Indians have been,
the Indians can see where you've been.
Now you learn how they do it,
you know,
what,
how the blades of grass turn and all of that.
I couldn't scout anything,
but,
uh,
that,
that you see how they do it and they become known as scouts,
which is sort of an Americanization of,
of a term.
And this is what he's,
he's,
uh,
he likes to do,
I mean,
Teddy Roosevelt,
you know,
there's a,
a good example of that.
I mean,
I talk about that kind of narcissism of,
of,
of uh,
uh,
you know,
of the colonial imagination and,
and imperial imagination.
Rough,
rough.
We're the stuff we want to fight and we can't get enough whoopee,
uh,
that,
the song of,
of the rough riders,
uh,
of,
you know,
from the,
the Cuban American war of Teddy Roosevelt.
So the,
so as part of the hysteria of the U s Spanish war,
but again,
it's the front tier a spirit.
Now,
Baden Paul helps create his own myth.
What's I've said,
he drew pictures of the people that he had allegedly shot these pictures and end
up being in the tabloid newspapers.
And again,
the role of the tabloids and spreading all this stuff is terribly important.
I said before,
they're 21 daily newspapers in Paris at the time.
And I don't remember how many there are in Britain,
but they're an awful lot of them.
Um,
he a sketch to a last stand of eight people supposedly until they get rescued,
uh,
against indigenous people.
Uh,
he claimed that the Zulus against whom the British war,
the Zulus Z,
u l u s called him quote,
sounds unlikely.
The man,
he who likes to lie down to shoot.
Uh,
and that the Ashanti called him in awe.
This was his term for himself.
He of the big hat.
Um,
and that in,
in this war,
uh,
in 1896 that they called him the wolf in awe.
Again,
his opponents,
the beast that does not sleep,
but sneaks around at night.
And so he became the wolf who never sleeps.
There's a slight problem with this invention of a term to describe himself as
the wolf who slept,
who sneaks around is there aren't any Wolfson Africa.
They're not any wolves at all.
So he made it up and made it up rather badly,
having taken it out of some book somewhere else.
But that doesn't stop the tabloids from referring to him as the wolf who never
sleeps.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
as though some of the,
and the Boers understand that.
And the,
the,
the Boer war that is the Dutch African or opposition opponents who by the way,
the British created the term concentration camp.
And again,
I'm not looking back from history,
uh,
but they're separating men and women.
I'm a children,
uh,
and,
and uh,
and women from the men and trying to avoid,
uh,
that they received provisioning out in,
out in the bush and they create the term concentration camp in the Boer war
where the bore with the bores.
You know,
we actually live there no,
and had for a long time though,
they're not an indigenous people.
They know that there aren't a wolves there.
And so they start mocking,
uh,
a Baden Paul.
Uh,
but,
uh,
he have the big hat did not slow down at all.
And so,
um,
in 1899,
he is the good luck to be at the siege of Mustang Musky Mfa,
King Maf,
a where they are surrounded by a force but not a terribly aggressive force.
And they,
and again,
he draws pictures of people on,
on,
on duty and,
and all of that night duty.
And the talented resisted 217 a days,
uh,
station on the railway line that runs between the Cape,
and,
and Rhodesia.
Um,
and um,
this,
this was a big takeoff for his,
uh,
his,
reputation and just the name Baden Powell,
the initials Baden Powell,
a BP become identified with British imperialism.
Um,
BP.
He loves the night and after his return from the hollows of the Veldt where he
has kept so many anxious vigils,
he lies awake hour after hour upon his camp mattress in the veranda tracing out
in his mind the various means and the agencies by which he can forestall the
bore move,
which are known to them.
He is personally already watched.
Uh,
he is the wolf who,
uh,
never sleeps.
Now BP also becomes those initials,
British pluck the idea that the British are mothers.
This is kind of a,
a image of would come out of the,
a very heroic,
you know,
Battle of Britain and,
and,
uh,
you know,
under,
under the bombs of,
of German Luftwaffe and World War II British plot.
Also BP,
British peerage,
British peers.
They know the upper classes,
the titled British peer says he becomes identified with,
uh,
with,
with all of this,
the wolf who,
uh,
who never sleeps.
His advice vice to his own,
um,
uh,
garrison is to,
um,
sit tight and shoot straight.
All is well here.
He writes,
I mean,
they're able to get messages out to the newspapers who are covering this.
Uh,
now again,
the British newspapers covered another siege,
which ends rather badly,
which is that in,
uh,
at cartoon with the death of,
of,
uh,
Charles Chinese Gordon as he was called Chinese Gordon because he slaughtered
the Chinese,
uh,
and he,
gets his,
uh,
Eh,
in,
um,
at Khartoum,
uh,
and of course children,
schoolchildren,
there's an enormous,
enormous outpouring of tears,
uh,
over the death of this man.
Uh,
and the,
the newspapers because of these modern techniques,
you know,
they can,
they can follow all of this stuff pretty much how the siege is going,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so BP the prince of Goodfellows,
Prince of Scouts,
uh,
here we go.
They emphasize his youth.
He's 43,
but he's youthful.
He's cheer,
cheerful.
He's always whistling and telling stories,
even when things are going bad.
Uh,
he loves pranks,
Childish Pranks.
This is from this,
some of the newspapers,
life was a game,
but you have to play it honorably.
And it was a game that silly women as he called them,
could not play.
Um,
and he becomes known again.
I'm sports.
Mass sports is starting just at this time.
The Olympics are starting just at this time.
Uh,
you know,
again,
there's a research and a of reality,
you know,
in the,
in these,
uh,
these Olympics.
Um,
uh,
he's called the gallon goalkeeper.
You know,
the guy they interviewed,
the goaltender of MF king.
Uh,
so a sports analogy becomes part again of,
of this imperial imperial thrust.
Um,
and uh,
they,
he,
they print patriotic letters to him,
which can be signed,
uh,
and it can be sent.
You can send a postcard,
you could send a postcard home.
Your parents have left after parents weekend.
If they came,
you can send them the following postcard.
Dear parents,
dear mom and dad,
we have shouted rule Britannia,
we have Sun God save the Queen.
We have toasted gallon,
a Baden I half a score.
We have sent our best respects to plucky must king and we have hoisted flags and
bunting in Galore with a wild and frenzied madness.
Born of joy.
The empire.
Cheers while we Britishers rejoiced to the land in this hour of jubilation,
I am sending you align with the wish that I could warmly shake your hand.
Years Exalted Lee and then you sign your,
your own name to it.
So scouting is someone said,
I can't remember,
which was,
uh,
which person was an attempt to make these values in quotes onto Gamion quotes,
a muff king permanent and to trace,
put,
trace them on the map of these countries.
Have these peoples all over,
uh,
other world 1909 newspapers said it may be that he is not a great soldier of the
sort,
which Napoleon or the mult keys or kitchen Kitchener's are made.
He is there.
Frontiersman the born leaders of irregulars a maverick,
uh,
and the empire has need of such a,
furthermore,
he has the knack of seizing the imagination of boys and a deep sympathy with
them.
He is doing his days work for the empire by training a number of manly little
fellows to keep their wits about them and their eyes,
skin.
We show a profit another day in a much greater affair than muff king.
And that of course is preparing for the war against those other peoples who
might contest British domination,
not the indigenous peoples,
but the other powers,
uh,
in Africa.
And so,
uh,
be prepared.
BP The same thing,
the same initials,
beaker it now that Sko,
anyone here a scout?
I had to memorize this stuff.
I could didn't get a single badge but at scout be prepared.
You're supposed to do that.
The Jam Burrito,
he creates these jam Marie's.
Um,
and,
um,
in May also at the same time,
I don't have time to talk about this,
but this is the same time when Arthur Conan Doyle Conan Doyle and you know,
the idea of sleuthing,
but it was sort of an urban sloofing for,
for evil doers in London and,
and sort of kind of merges a with all of that.
Um,
and of boys who risked their life,
he says,
I said to one of these boys on one occasion when he came through a rather heavy
fire,
you will get hit one of these days writing about like that and when shells are
flying.
And he replied,
sir,
I pedal so quickly they'll never catch me.
Those boys don't seem to mind the bullets one bit.
And of course millions of them would catch bullets that ultimately they serve
they minded.
Um,
I will do my best to God and the king.
I will do my best to help others.
Whatever it costs me,
I know the Scout Law and I will obey it.
Again,
I am not knocking,
doing good things for people.
Please do understand,
but I'm just trying to place the origins of whatever you think of the boy scouts
in the context of the imperialism of,
of uh,
the culture of imperialism.
Cause that's where it belongs.
And that's where it started.
In 1912 in August,
a boat capsized off the coast of Devon,
I think,
and nine boys from 11 to 14,
drown.
They were scouts.
Um,
and there was an enormous,
enormous,
uh,
of national funeral service in London in which millions of people,
saw at least parts of it,
uh,
this helped their death and many more deaths would follow.
Help tie it together.
The idea of scouting with service,
uh,
to,
the nation,
um,
a magazine called the captain,
again,
this is part of,
of,
of the culture of imperialism and of aggressive nationalism.
Had a troop of mobile scouts on bikes have fitted with a rifle,
beck bucket and a clip to carry a carbine,
a rival.
Uh,
and so it,
it shifts that the image of all of this shifts from,
from Africa where,
uh,
where much of the fighting was already over and indigenous people,
destroyed or pacified to,
uh,
the European enemies against whom the next tour would be,
fought.
Um,
there's a famous cartoon in the British,
um,
and magazine punch,
which showed a boy scout you complete in uniform,
being prepared,
taking Mrs Britannia.
That is the image of Victoria who was dead,
but the female image of the empire by the arm and says,
fear not grandma.
No danger can befall you.
I,
after all,
remember I am with you now.
Boy Scouts played an enormous role in,
uh,
in 1914 and in the subsequent years.
Good,
good bye.
I'm off to war.
Uh,
there was,
uh,
a cartoon or a character in the newspaper as,
as boy scouts joined up along with lots of other people who weren't scouts,
uh,
in the war.
And as you well know,
um,
they don't come back or a lot of them,
uh,
don't come,
don't come back.
It's part of the mood of nationalism and of imperialism,
of the new imperialism.
And two things are tied
together and the expectation,
and indeed in many cases,
in the case of Baden Paul,
joyous expectation that you could test your virility in a more meaningful camp
combat than simply slaughtering indigenous people or picking off bores,
uh,
with greater,
numerical superiority.
By the way,
Baden Powell,
Robert Baden Powell died in Kenya in 1941 from which he had just sent his last
patriotic message to the boy scouts in what was a very different war.
Thank you.
I'll see you on Wednesday.